I know people are anxiously awaiting
hatred mail this week let me not delay
any further and remind you what we are
talking about when we're talking about
hatred mail a fine Rand and Ronald
Reagan had a baby and suckled that child
of the teat of Liberty its cries would
sound a little something like Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom exactly so let's jump right into
this week's hatred mail it's a little
longer than some it's a little wackier
than some as well David Parkman the only
one humiliating himself is you lowlife
liberal loser how come you're so stupid
we can only guess by just looking at you
first your nose covers almost all your
face so were to believe that your expert
newsman what is your expertise most
likely stupid teehee and ignorance get a
life and a real job because you suck big
time at what you think you're doing do
us all a big favor and get off this
channel ad get a real job like cleaning
sewers or garbage pickup or go to a
garbage dump and pick through it maybe
you can find yourself a better suit or a
good used toothbrush that's a great job
for you [ __ ] post by VL yeah I
account if you don't include the fact
that there's not a single period in this
entire hatred mail I count six or seven
spelling and grammar errors and I don't
want to focus on those I actually want
to focus on what what is being pointed
out there what does the size of my nose
have to do with my credibility unless
and you know I don't even really have to
say it unless there is some implicit
bias based on the characteristics that
this person is assigning to my nose I
think we all know where that's going
and again this whole thing about getting
a real job I'm almost starting to think
that some of our viewers the hatreds
sort of resent that this is my real job
and I think for that we can all be glad
remember you can turn hatred mail
something positive by using the coupon
code hey tree at forty h80
our IOT forty at david pakman.com slash
membership